um the health secretary just announcing
that he has tested positive
for covert 19. this is his tweet
as you can see we're getting that video
um as soon as we can but he's that's
what he said
javed this morning i tested positive for
covert 19 let's have a listen to the
video
hi everyone i just wanted to update you
all that i've tested positive for covid
i was feeling a bit groggy last night so
i took a lateral flow test this morning
and it's come out positive
so i'm now self-isolating at home with
my family until i get the results of a
pcr test
i'm grateful that i've had two jabs of
the vaccine and so far
my symptoms are very mild and i also
want to take this opportunity to thank
everyone that's been involved in our
national vaccine rollout program truly
the
best of its kind anywhere in the world
if you haven't had your jobs yet
please get out there and get them as
soon as you can
and if like me you might feel a bit
groggy
or you think you might have come into
contact with someone who's positive
please also take a lateral flow test too
if everyone plays their part
you're not only protecting yourself and
your loved ones but you're also
safeguarding the nhs and helping to
preserve our way of life
thank you